la cérémonie des césar avec quatre
récompenses pour le fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain pas forcément le record
attendu puisque ce film avait été treize
fois nominée mais il reste largement
gagnant il obtient le césar du meilleur
film et de la meilleure réalisation
les moments forts de cette soirée avec
pascal deschamps s'il y avait comme
d'habitude dans la salle hier soir
beaucoup de candidats et peu d'élus si
lieu comme d'habitude quelques
déceptions
ce palmarès est épatant parce qu'à
l'image de la fabuleuse année du cinéma
français alors ce soir notre succès
dégustons le jean pierre jeunet amélie
poulain n'a pas battu le record du
dernier métro est alors le film repart
avec quatre césars pour treize
nominations à la bonne heure le bonheur
qu'il aura donné à 9 millions de ce
précepte voit bien sûr j'aurais aimé que
mon chef opérateur gagne que mon moteur
gage peuvent vous faire la liste de tous
le monde bien sûr j'aurais aimé tout le
monde gagne mais en même temps c'est pas
mal que qu'il y en a un peu pour tout le
monde c'est sain c'est plutôt sain voilà
je vais aller pleurer avec eux avec les
perdants et on va rire avec les gagnants
mais j'aime beaucoup sur mes lèvres je
suis ravi qu'il ait gagné des choses
c'est sur ses lèvres qu'il fallait lire
le bonheur d'emmanuelle devos meilleure
actrice pour son rôle de soude dans un
polar signé jacques audiard qui repart
avec le césar du meilleur scénario
pas du tout
et puis là satan c'est la consécration
corps gravel c'est bon je suis pour
s'écraser
jamel debbouze devront attendre encore
un peu c'est andré dussollier qui repart
avec le césar du meilleur second rôle
tout comme annie girardot admirable dans
la pianiste merci pour cet honneur que
vous me faites je suis très heureuse
on attendait plus elle est arrivée
profitant de l'entracte de ruy blas
qu'elle joue à la comédie-française
chaos voir rachida brakni le césar du
meilleur espoir
mes parents m'ont appris que j'étais
nommé pour les césars
mon père ne savait pas très bien ce que
c'était je veux expliquer le principe et
il était fou de rage parce qu'il m'a dit
encore un concours quand est ce que tu
vas finir avec tes examens
on retiendra aussi les larmes de jean
françois stévenin pour son meilleur
espoir de fiston le césar du meilleur
acteur de michel bouquet qu'il n'avait
jamais eu l'émotion de danielle darrieux
bref on retiendra l'image d'un cinéma
français fier et heureux de ces 40% de
parts de marché du jamais vu depuis
quinze ans